this guy you can pencil him in for all
pro not pro bowl now none of that
nonsense this is just Pro Bowl Joe
Thomas has done it I think now seven
times in his career of my Cleveland
Browns the offensive tackle and Joe kind
enough to join us after the wheel of
punishment where the danettes laughed at
my prediction that the Browns would win
at least one game Joe we did it we got
that win congratulations we did it so
much for having me on where are you
right now I am actually in beautiful
Cleveland Ohio yeah pretty this time of
year ended you know what we actually
just got a little dusting of snow so
it's a beautiful winter wonderland out
there right now what is losing do to you
well I think it motivates you to work
harder to try to get that bad taste out
of your mouth but also you get mean you
get a win but after a while it has to
eat at you to a certain degree you
you've played at a Hall of Fame level I
mean you've been an all-pro seven times
it's rare when you get somebody you know
that has that accomplishment who doesn't
go into the hall of fame but you're not
winning I mean how do you not take that
home with you after yet another loss
well it is tough I think losing in the
NFL is one of those things that people
on the outside that have never played or
coached don't really understand how
difficult and painful it really can be
and it really does eat away at you and I
think it's one of those things that you
have to learn to not take the losing
home with you because if you do it can
really ruin your family life you can
ruin your home life because it can be so
painful mentally that it really affects
your life in a terrible way what was
that feeling like in the locker room
after the win over San Diego
well it really was emotional i think um
i don't know if people know it but we
actually lost every preseason game this
year too so even up even that place of
winning in exhibition diseases was not
there for us though that that agony of
walking into that locker room for 18
straight week of looking at your coaches
and your teammates and and seeing the
the paint on their face of another loss
was really difficult to bear and to
finally have that payoff that joyous
victory I think a lot of people in that
locker room or kind of overcome with
emotion best team you face this year
that's in the playoffs still in the
playoffs assu New England you guys lost
what 3313 to the Patriots you know I
don't remember the score I feel like the
first beginning of that game was
competitive and then they kind of walked
away with it in the second half that was
Brady's first game back from suspension
and you could tell he was playing with a
little extra chip on his shoulder uh you
lost to the cowboys lost the Steelers
yep you know a lot of light my back Joe
my bad you played the cowboy you blade
this dealers he played the Patriots how
is the game changed since you uh hell I
think I talked to you on draft day you
were hunting you didn't even go to the
draft is that right yeah I was busy I
was busy a prior engagement so so how is
it how is the game changed since then
yeah well it's changed in a lot of
facets I think from my standpoint I
think the defense's that we see weekend
and week out have changed a lot i think
the blitz schemes are much more complex
I think you see many teams playing
hybrid 4334 defenses that maybe aren't
as gap sound as they were early on in my
career but I think defenses are taking
more chances whereas when I first got in
a league I think more defenses want to
be fundamentally sound and they they
kind of picked and
their chances and their situations to
maybe make a blitz to try to make a big
play whereas now I think defenses
realized how good offices are in order
to stop them they have to make a big
play on every every Drive in order to
keep a team out of the end zone so they
do take some more of those risks in
those chances and there are much more
complex you weigh what 310 is that right
can you let yourself go in the offseason
you know I've never been a guy that
blows up and gained a lot of weight I've
always kind of been a skinnier guy that
has to kind of put weight on as the
season comes up to play at that 310 315
range so I never I've been lucky I've
never had to really worry about getting
too big in the offseason I the wheel of
punishment I of course bought into the
Cleveland Browns thought you guys were
going to win two games but the haters on
the other side of the glass the danettes
they laughed at me your thoughts on the
wheel of punishment that the danettes
faced well I I do appreciate you picking
up to win two games and I say us because
you are considered a Cleveland Brown
since you were picking on our side yes
but I'm a little bit disappointed in
seaton and Paulie I do watch the show
and it sounds like there was a bet that
has been unpaid for yet and it looks
like they still have a full beard and I
think they're supposed to shave half
their face and if they're unwilling to
shave half their faith I'm unfortunately
going to have to come to the studio and
we'll have to do a good old-fashioned
one-on-one live hamburger drill me a
versus Cena the neighbors poly since
they don't want to pay up their debt Oh
Paulie somebody get me a razor quick I
would rather shave my face and face that
monster I'm shaving I gave them the
opportunity though Joe I was looking for
content I thought I could get two pieces
of content instead of just one where
they had to shave just one side of their
face so if you want to blame anybody
blame me because I I wanted to make sure
that I was getting a little more out of
them they let the punishments spread out
a little bit we'll give him a pass than
this time could you
kill them if you wanted to how much time
do I have how much times you take if I
gave you 10 minutes I think that's all
I'd need so more than 15 seconds to kill
Seaton and Polly uh together I'd need 30
seconds 30 seconds ever know if one
starts running away you know that it
might take a few seconds to catch catch
the other one after I've killed the
first 1i have you done an octagon stuff
of you are you interested in any of them
um mildly earlier in my career I
actually did some MMA martial arts type
training in the offseason to kind of
work on my hands and I enjoyed that type
of stuff but I think if I got in the
ring now one kick to my knees and I
piece fall down and third crying for my
mommy what do you have ten time Pro Bowl
tackle and hung up is that right yeah
ten-four temporal is this correct and
how many all pros oh I think eight you
think eight appreciate ya like if I had
to guess I don't keep tabs of that on a
daily basis but that's but I I got I got
eight eight straight all-pro selections
that's Hall of Fame stuff Joe someday I
do hope to be in the Hall of Fame that
was a goal of mine when I first got in
the NFL have you uh well who gets in
first you or JJ one well I'm guessing
he'll probably have a longer career than
I will so he's a little younger than I
am so I imagine I'll probably retire and
be eligible before he will he doesn't
get enough camera time Joe I'm worried
about JJ van Gogh we're all feeling bad
for him hardly had any exposure to do
your being injured at all ok good luck
in the offseason there and I'll be
rooting for the Browns next year cuz i
think we double our win total at least
and i will count the preseason games now
I never paid attention to the preseason
games but I will with the Cleveland
Browns starting next year ago you're so
kind thank you Joe that's a joke Thomas
browns offensive tackle the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]